thousands trapped on a cruise liner with
a deadly virus on board ten have already
tested positive for corona virus but
hundreds more results have yet to come
back passengers have been told to
isolate themselves all passengers have
to remain in their cabins we can't open
the door and walk along the corridor we
are confined at a cabin for the duration
of the cruise pictures inside appear to
show officials checking on cabins all
the ship's communal areas seem to be
deserted fear is spreading as quickly as
the virus itself this is Hong Kong and
another cruise ship with all passengers
and crew told to stay on board whilst
health checks are done after 30 of the
crew complained of being ill the ones we
managed to make contact with didn't seem
on Julie perturbed are you worried they
said they weren't and clearly weren't
being isolated with many still walking
around freely but with the virus and
spreading the UK government ordered
another evacuation this Sunday to
airlift Britain's trapped in the
outbreak epicenter it follows the
Foreign Office advice to Britons to get
out of China if they can that's
increasingly difficult for some john
hall has a newborn with no passport and
a chinese wife with no visa they mean
the world to me and if anything happens
to my daughter and my wife I would be
devastated I know he's probably quiche
but you've probably heard this before
but it's true they are my life and as a
husband I need to protect them as much
as I can
I've got a lot of dry foods but other
Britons are staying put in China I think
the risk of taking a flight is still
quite high at the moment and then
putting people back home in that
situation to me doesn't seem fair and
basically for the last two weeks at
least there's not been anything going on
many people in Beijing it seems are
staying inside and pictures we've been
sent the
from Fujio in East China seemed to show
draconian measures to keep people off
the streets these notices permit one
person per household out every two days
the virus panic is at its most acute
across the border from the mainland in
Hong Kong
many of the only masks available of ten
times the price now crazy this Gong
sound nobody
I think it's acceptable actually because
the price is actually well it's not a
good time to be making profit for their
own business all travelers from the
mainland to Hong Kong now phase two
weeks quarantine the next fortnight in
both China and its semi-autonomous
region will be critical to see if the
breaks can be put on this virus Alex
Crawford Sky News Hong Kong